こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
なんか最近ガチャガチャに
すごいなんか気を張ってて
すごいガチャがあるという話を聞いて
それをちょっと買ってきました
えっと名前はね　確かね
なんだっけな．．．
名前があるんですよね
えっと名前がね、なんだっけな．．．
『シャクレプラネット』　だ
そう、シャクレプラネットっていう
ふっふっふっ
シャクレプラネットっていうガチャがあるみたいです
どんなガチャガチャかな？と思ってみたんですけど
なんか動物なんすよ
動物のフィギュアが出るガチャガチャなんですけども
全部の動物がしゃくれてて
あごがね、こう
あごがこうなってるんすよ
ふふっ
笑っちゃダメだ
何が面白いんだ
あの、シャクレプラネッ．．．
ネーミングセンス
シャクレプラネットっていうガチャがあるんですけども
あのね
聞いてくれよ
これを買うの　すごい大変だったよ
イトーヨーカドーが近くにあるんですけども
調べたんすよ　インターネットで
『シャクレプラネット売り場』って調べて
調べたら俺ん家の近くの
イトーヨーカドーなら
シャクレプラネットが売ってるよって言われたんで
僕はシャクレプラネットが欲しかったんで
イトーヨーカドーまで
シャクレプラネットのガチャをしに行ったんすよ
そしたら
シャクレプラネット売り切れです
ガチャガチャ
これ結構最近出たんですよ
最近出たのにもう売り切れって
どんだけシャクレプラネット売れてるんだよって話っすよ
で、もうパニクっちゃって
やばいシャクレプラネットが手に入らねぇと思って
シャクレプラネットで次に近いところ調べたら
次はヤマダ電機
ガチャガチャコーナーに行ったら
ありました！
どうしてもシャクレプラネットが欲しかったんで
絶対買おうと思ってたんで
そこでもう僕の財布にある１００円玉全部使って
シャクレプラネット８個買ってきました
イトーヨーカドーで売り切れてたから
絶対人気なんですよ
もうみんなね
そう　しゃくれた動物が欲しすぎて
社会現象みたいになってるはずです
で、全６種類なんですけど
被ることを考えて８個買いました
では早速シャクレプラネット開けていきましょう
いやー楽しみ
うっ
なんだ今のは
謎の圧力を感じたぞ
とりあえず開けていきましょう
パッケージとかもちゃんと見てなかったんで
どんなシャクレプラネットがでるか
わかっ
ははははっ
一人目はこの子です
これはコアラかな
コアラが当たりました
パッと見　普通のコアラなんですけども
まぁ横から見るとこういう感じです
ははははっ
うわっ
ぐっ
はっ！
また頭痛が
なんなんだ今日は
はい、どんどん開けていきましょう
しゃくれしゃく．．．
おぉ！
デカい！
ははっ
２匹目はこちら
パンダです
まぁパッと見なんの変哲もないパンダなんですけども
まぁ横から見ると
こういう感じです
なんでこんなの作ろうと思ったんだろう
はっはっはっは
うわぁ
ぐっ
うぅっ
うわぁっ
なんだ．．？
あご？
分からない
変な力を感じる今日は
では次行ってみましょう
いや、今のところ被ってないからね
いい調子だよ
じゃあ次行きます
かぶった！！
やばい　もう被っちゃった
待って　もう被っちゃったんですけど
やばいよ
あと一回しか被れませんからね
次行きましょう
４個目行きましょう
おぉ！
新入り新入り！
新入り
えぇ？普通？え？
これ普通じゃね？
パッと見　普通なんですけども
横から見ると
しゃくれております
こいつでもそんなに重症ってほどでもないですね
すごいしゃくれメンバーが揃って来てますね
うわぁ！　ぐっ
ぐっ
はっ！
なんなんだ今日は
じゃあ次行きましょう
５個目！
被ってほしくない
全部集めたい
来い！
おぉー！来たー！
ははっ
はい、５匹目はライオンでございます
なんかジワるんだよね
横から見てもこんなひどいしゃくれです
あと３つで
もう　１、２、３、４種類出てるんで
あと２種類出れば
オールコンプリートです
じゃあ行きましょう
あ、めっちゃ軽い
え、これめっちゃ軽いよ
行きます！
おぉ！新入りだ！
え、二人いる
二人いる二人いる
なんかこれ誰だろう？
シャクレルミーアキャット．．
シャクレルミーアキャット
ルミーアキャットですね
こちらルミーアキャットです
こいつらも完全にしゃくれてます
いよいよあと１種類ですよー
２つであと１種類出たら　もう勝ちですからね
では開けていきましょう
あー被ったー
ライオンです
もうやばいよ
不気味な光景すぎるよ
あー重いな
重い
ラスト１個重いです
ガチなほうでコンプリートしたい
もう一人いれば全部揃う
では開けます！
ではラスト開けてみようと思います
うっ
ぐわっ
ごっ
うわぁ
うわぁ　やめてくれ！
くっ
あごっ
ぬわぁぁ
くっ
あごっ
はっ！
なんだ今のは
なんなんだこれは
しゃくしゃくー
うわぁぁ！
しゃくしゃくしゃくー
ト、トミックさん？
あごごー
トミックさんだ．．．
しゃくしゃくしゃくー
ま、まさか
しゃくれているから
魂が移ってしまった
ははは
あごご―
うるせー